♪ ♪
Greg: HAPPY TUESDAY, EVERYONE.
WELL, IT'S OFFICIAL, I WONDER IF
THE PRESIDENT WILL PROFOUNDLY
ACCEPT THE NOMINATION FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AFTER BEING NOMINATED.
>> I PROFOUNDLY ACCEPT THIS
NOMINATION FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
[CHEERS]
Greg: IT IS HAPPENING.
YEAH, THE RAID WAS A REAL SMART
MOVE.
YOU WANT TO TAKE A
LARGER-THAN-LIFE CHARACTER AND
MAKE HIM EVEN LARGER?
YOU RAID HIS HOUSE.
THEY JUST GAVE POP A 55-OUNCE
CAN OF SPINACH.
THEY SAVED HUNTER BIDEN'S
HIGH-SPEED INTERNET ACCESS.
HE JUST GAVE ME A BOOK OF 1000
AND ONE JOKES.
BECAUSE THE RAID NOT ONLY ANGERS
REPUBLICANS, IT ENERGIZES THEM
AND IT ENERGIZES DONALD TRUMP.
ON UNLIKE ALL THE OTHER SHOWS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TAPE AND FOOTAGE
OF THE RAID.
♪ ♪
♪
Greg: IT IS WRONG, BUT YOU
HAVE TO KEEP YOUR SENSE OF HUMOR
ON THIS FOR A REASON.
PART OF THE STRATEGY IS TO GET
YOU TO REACT.
SO THAT THEY CAN THEN COVER YOUR
ANGER AS DANGER.
THE PRESS HAS ALREADY BEEN
SOUNDING THE ALARM OVER THE
PRO-TRUMP MESSAGE BOARDS AND
THEY ARE READY TO GO, THEY SAY.
SO DON'T GET MAD.
INSTEAD, SYMPATHIZE.
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD LIKE DONALD
TRUMP, THEY CAN'T SURVIVE
WITHOUT HIM, THEY ARE DROWNING
AND HE IS THERE OXYGEN.
THEY ARE JUST TOO BORING AND
UNINSPIRING.
AND MAYBE IT IS BECAUSE THEIR
CURRENT LEADER IS TAPIOCA FOR
BRAINS.
AND SO THEY WILL DO ANYTHING TO
KEEP THE SPOTLIGHT OFF HIM AND
CAN YOU BLAME THEM?
THIS GUY GETS IN A FIGHT WITH
HIS OWN CLOTHES.
AND ROLL IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH, MY GOD, WEIGHT, THERE IS
MORE.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GIVE HIM TIME, HE WILL
REMEMBER WHERE THE ARMHOLES ARE
SOMEDAY.
THANKFULLY IT WAS A JACKET AND
NOT HIS PANTS.
BUT IT IS ALSO KIND OF SCARY
WHEN IT TAKES SECONDS FOR JOE TO
FORGET THAT HE JUST SHOOK
SOMEBODY'S HAND.
>> NOW OUR GREAT SPEAKER --
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS THE CRAZIEST THING I
HAVE EVER SEEN.
AND NO WONDER THEY EYED HIM LIKE
A COLD SORE AT A KISSING BOOTH.
WHAT GIVES, JOE.
>> COME ON, MAN.
[LAUGHTER]
Greg: MUCH OF THE COUNTRY WILL
BE UPSET OVER THE RAID, THE REST
EMBRACED IN THE NEWS LIKE A BOX
OF KLEENEX.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO WANT TO BUY
THE NEWSPAPER AND FOLDED
CAREFULLY.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, THIS IS A NIGHT YOU ARE
GOING TO REMEMBER WHERE YOU
WERE.
>> THERE IS ALSO THIS LYING
ADVANTAGE, THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT
GOING TO LIE.
>> AND FACT THAT WEAK PEOPLE ARE
RUNNING AROUND, I MEAN, WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO DO, THEY ARE SAYING
UGLY THINGS ON FOX NEWS.
>> WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
LIKE, THE GUY IS GOING TO BE
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE, HE'S BROKEN
THE LAW AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT.
Greg: WELL, HIP HIP HOORAY.
THIS IS FOR PEOPLE THAT DO
NOTHING BUT PUT DEMOCRACY UNDER
ASSAULT.
SO THE RAID IS ABOUT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, YOU DIDN'T NEED A
RAID AT ALL.
BUT THEY ALSO KNOW WHAT MAKES
FOR EXCITING VIDEO, AND AS ANDY
MCCARTHY POINTS OUT, IT'S LIKELY
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
PRESSURING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
SADLY THE FBI SEEMS LIKE AN
INSTITUTION POLLUTED BY
POLITICS, BUT THEY PUNISH YOU BY
INVESTIGATING SOME AND NOT
OTHERS, I COULD GO THROUGH THE
LIST, BUT YOU'VE HEARD IT, AT
LEAST ON THIS NETWORK YOU HAVE,
IF THEY WERE ANY DEEPER IN THE
SWAMP THEY WOULD HAVE ALLIGATORS
FOR BABY MAMAS.
DISGUSTING.
>> ESPECIALLY AFTER PUSHING THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
I MEAN, THEY SHOW UP AT THE
HOUSE, THEY GO THROUGH HIS SAFE,
WHICH IS WHY I DON'T HAVE A
SAFE, I KEEP EVERYTHING BETWEEN
MY MATTRESS AND MY BOX SPRINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THANK GOD THAT DOLL IS EASY
TO INFLATE.
[LAUGHTER]
SOME LEVITY.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE IMPLODING.
MAYBE IT IS DUE TO WOKEISM OR
PLAIN OLD ELITISM, IT'S A FAR
CRY WHEN THEY KNEW TO KEEP THE
POLITICS AT BAY, IF THEY DON'T
COME OUT WITH ONE MAJOR SMOKING
GUN FROM THAT RAID, AND I MEAN A
MAJOR ONE, THEN THEY WILL HAVE A
COUNTRY THAT IS MORE UPSET THAN
R. KELLY AFTER 2 QUARTS OF
SNAPPLE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE DOING THIS TO
JOE BIDEN OR BARACK OBAMA OR
HILLARY CLINTON?
COME TO THINK OF IT MAYBE THEY
SHOULD DO IT FOR BILL CLINTON.
Greg: THE FBI THINKS THAT THEY
ARE THE COUNTRY DESPITE THEIR
BANANA REPUBLIC ANTICS.
THEY KEEP PULLING TO THE LEFT
AND THE ENGINE LIGHT HAS COME ON
FOR THE 10TH TIME, THEY HAVE RUN
OUT OF ELECTRICAL TAPE TO HIDE
IT, WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM UNDER THE HOOD, IT'S ALL
THESE SUPPOSEDLY NEUTRAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVING CHOSEN A
TEAM.
IT WOULD COST US TO GET A NEW
CAR BUT WE SHOULD REPLACE THE
DRIVETRAIN AND A COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
LAST NIGHTS RAID WAS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF ONE-WAY PERSECUTION
WHERE THEY PAY YOU A VISIT AND
IT'S UP TO YOU TO PROVE YOUR
INNOCENCE.
IT'S THE SAME MENTALITY WITH THE
IRS AGENT, HEY, YOU HAVE NOTHING
TO HIDE, SO WHO WILL THEY GO FOR
NEXT?
MAYBE YOU WILL, MAYBE ME.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT IN
PREPARATION FOR THE RAID I MOVE
MY COLLECTION OF BEANIE BABIES
OUT OF THE HOUSE.
AND SOME PEOPLE WOULD NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT.
ALL RIGHT, WELCOMING OUR GUESTS
NOW TONIGHT.
SHE NEVER BLUNDERS.
♪ ♪
♪ HARRIS FAULKNER.
>> AND VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
RELATIONS, CHRIS BARRON.
AND SHE'S LIKE A DOORMAT,
WELCOMING ON YOUR PORCH OFTEN
TIMES, KAT TIMPF.
AND FINALLY HE WANTED TO BE A
FOOTBALL KICKER BUT THEY KEPT
RUNNING OUT OF BALLS.
OUR CHAMPION TYRUS.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO I AM SURE THAT YOU HAVE
TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT, DO YOU
THINK OF THIS STORY IS ABOUT
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS OR
SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON?
>> WELL, IT IS A WAR ABOUT
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FROM THOSE
THAT ALREADY HANDED OVER WHAT
THEY HAD THOUGHT ABOUT OR NOT,
IT WOULD BE PART OF THE ARGUMENT
AND THEN YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT
HOW TO GET MORE OF WHATEVER IS
THERE.
BUT FROM ONE OF OUR
CORRESPONDENCE, ABOUT AN HOUR
AND A HALF AGO, REPORTING THAT
ACCORDING TO FOX NEWS SOURCES,
THE NEGOTIATIONS OF SOME SORT
HAVE BROKEN DOWN AND THAT'S WHY
THEY GOT THE WARRANT.
>> GOING NUCLEAR.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT THEY COULD SIMPLY SAY
OUTSIDE WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING THE
CASE, THE DOJ IS A MESS RIGHT
NOW AND THEY STAY SILENT ALL
DAY.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
GROUPS OF ALL TIME, THAT
INCLUDES THE JACKET AND SHIRT
COMBO RIGHT THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I KNOW YOU'RE JEALOUS, I KNOW
YOU'RE JEALOUS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I MEAN, THE THING IS THAT YOU
GET ANGRY THEN WHAT IS NEXT?
>> WELL, THERE IS A BOSTON GLOBE
ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT, LIKE THE
RIGHT WING ANGERING VIOLENCE,
THIS IS THE THING THAT DRIVES ME
TO CRAZIEST ABOUT THIS, THEY SAY
THAT WE HAVE TO GIVE THE DOJ,
THE FBI, THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
ABSOLUTE [BLEEP] AND IF YOU ARE
GOING TO CROSS THE LINE AND READ
THE CHIEF POLITICAL OPPOSITION,
MOST LIKELY TO BE RUNNING IN
2024, THE FBI THEN HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO COME OUT AND SAY
WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON, WHY
WAS THIS NECESSARY, WHY DID THEY
CROSS THIS LINE, WE SHOULD NOT
BE GUESSING OVER IT'S THIS OR
THAT.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO CROSS THE
LINE, YOU BETTER COME FORWARD
AND MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THERE WAS
A DARN GOOD REASON TO DO THIS.
>> IT'S NOT NORMAL, IT IS NOT
NORMAL.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> DO YOU EVER WORRY ABOUT BEING
RATED?
I MEAN, NOW YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THEY DID SO
TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> SOME OF US HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND JUST HEARING ALL THESE
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT, THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THESE VERY
POWERFUL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES, LIBERTARIANS OVER HERE
LIKE YEAH, HILLARY HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THAT, IF YOU ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES POTENTIALLY
BEING POLITICIZED, YOU SHOULD
NOT TALK ABOUT HOW THAT'S MADE
POSSIBLE, I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT, THE SAME
PEOPLE REPEATEDLY VOTED TO
REAUTHORIZE THE PATRIOT ACT.
SO I HOPE THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE LEARNED IN TERMS
OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT SIDE YOU ARE ON WHEN
THESE AGENCIES HAVE THIS KIND OF
POWER.
>> WOULD YOU BE OKAY WITH
EXPANDING THE FBI?
>> THE FBI HAS FAR TOO MUCH
POWER, FAR TOO MUCH POWER.
>> I WILL ADMIT, THAT I AM
PROBABLY ONE OF THE PEOPLE YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT IN THE SENSE
THAT YOU KNOW, NOW THEY ARE
USING THE PATRIOT ACT OR THEY
ARE READY TO TRACK DOWN CITIZENS
IN THE UNITED STATES IN THIS
WAY.
>> YES, YES.
>> SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS, TYRUS?
>> THIS IS PHENOMENAL, THIS
WOULD GET ME HYPED.
I MEAN, LIKE OKAY, GAME ON.
YOU GOT THE BOOKKEEPER, YOU GOT
NOTHING.
I'VE GOT THE BEST LAWYER.
EVERY CLICHÉ FROM EVERY MOVIE.
WE'VE BEEN THERE, WE HAVE DONE
THIS, AND JOAN OF ARC, SHE CAME
ON AND SAID WE GOT THE PAPERS
AND WE GOT THEM, NO, WE'VE GOT
NOTHING.
SO AGAIN, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THINGS, AND I GUESS I LIKE
SPITE.
I GUESS WE WILL HAVE A SPITEFUL
PRESIDENT AND I COULDN'T BE
HAPPIER.
YOU GO TO MY HOUSE, YOU TRY TO
EMBARRASS ME.
THE MAN WHO CANNOT BE
EMBARRASSED?
I MEAN, HE SAID OBAMA MADE JOKES
ABOUT HIM AT A PARTY.
>> IT'S LITERALLY LIKE OKAY,
GAME ON, HE'S FIRED UP, I'M
GOING TO SIT BACK AND JUST
WATCH.
THERE MIGHT BE A POSITION FOR ME
IN THIS.
I FEEL LIKE I LOVE IT.
>> SO TONIGHT, JIM BANKS AND
ABOUT A DOZEN OTHER REPUBLICANS
ARE MEETING.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING AS YOU
TALK ABOUT IT, THAT IS A
GALVANIZING POINT.
MAYBE THEY DID NOT AGREE ON
POLICY, MAYBE THEY HAVEN'T
AGREED, BUT HE LEGITIMATELY HAS
NOW BROUGHT MORE PEOPLE TOGETHER
JUST BECAUSE HE WASN'T HOME.
I MEAN, DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
WOULD'VE DONE THIS, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT.
>> I WOULD'VE BEEN WORRIED IF
NANCY PELOSI DID NOT SAY HEY, NO
ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
FOR REAL?
>> I DON'T REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT DESTROYING SOMEBODY'S
CAR AND NOT BEING CHARGED.
>> NANCY PELOSI, ALSO
PRESIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS SHE SAID
SHOULD BE PRESERVED, I THINK SHE
WAS THE ONE THAT TALKED ABOUT
THAT.
>> AS I SAID, IT IS ALL GOOD,
MAN.
>> IT IS ENTERTAINING TO WATCH
THE LEFT DEFEND THE FBI, HE
SPENT YEARS WIRETAPPING, TRYING
TO SET THEM UP, SENDING HIM
BLACK MALE LETTERS, THEY ARE
SAYING THAT YOU CAN'T EVEN